my name is
melvin friedman uh
i i am retired from the government
after 48 years of service i'm currently
an academic affiliate at george mason
university
i would like to acknowledge the help of
my
colleague brian mark this work
was done in collaboration with him
we typically spend one hour a week
for a period of a year and this talk
and other work are the result of those
conversations
now i go on to my next slide the
fundamental problem we considered is
this
is it possible to design a road traffic
control system
and road to travel a feedback system
that simultaneously satisfies
these properties a motorist
traveling at a recommended constant
average speed
in any one of four orthogonal directions
makes every traffic light in their
chosen direction
regardless of their starting point or
how far they travel in the chosen
direction
although i'm not going to cover it in
this presentation
the same is also true for pedestrians
and bicyclists
another demand another part of the
fundamental problem is
we require that the system have maximum
potential flow
we also require that the system be
capable of adapting to me changing
traffic demand
now an interesting question then is does
the problem have a solution even if one
forgets about
the bicyclists and pedestrians it is not
clear that the stated problem has a
solution
the problem however does have a solution
for motorist bicyclists and pedestrians
here we're going to focus on motorists
the concepts of designed road system
red sea green waves
and green arrows really help to solve
the fundamental problem
so now now i'll
talk about some of those things
there are three road systems that we're
considering
a cartesian grid of alternate one-way
roads
a cartesian grid of two-way roads and a
cartesian grid
with a combination of one and two-way
roads
you might not be familiar what a grid of
alternate one-way roads
are and that's illustrated in this
figure
here you see streets go alternately west
east west east and they ultimately go
north south north and south
so that's what we mean by a cartesian
grid of alternate one-way roads
for this system of roads the gray
squares are nominally
a half a mile on the side
and not shown in the diagram
are minor streets and if these are half
a mile
on a side that means there are several
streets going north and south and east
and west
in each of these gray squares i'll now
show you what we mean by a cartesian
grid
of two-way roads
here you can see there are two-way roads
because there's traffic heading
west east on the same road
and there's traffic heading north and
south on the same road
and that's true of every road in the
system
here the gray squares are nominally one
mile on the side
and minus streets within the gray
squares are not shown
the third class of road that we'll
consider
is is this
here we have a cartesian grid of one and
two-way roads
once again these uh
these race squares are nominally one
mile on the side
and here you see we have traffic heading
north and south on the same street and
we have traffic
heading east and west on the same street
however here i've designated two streets
where traffic is only heading west
this one and this one so that this is
what we call
a a mixed uh a mixed
road system i've now defined
the road system that i'm considering now
i'm going to define what i mean by a red
sea
but there are actually two kinds of red
seas one is
a digital red sea in which you imagine
all the traffic lights in the city
and in the surrounding suburbs are red
in all four orthogonal directions
that's the digital red sea the
continuous red sea
is a conceptual uh thing that
helps you relate better to how the
digital red sea works
you can imagine red lights are are
are samples on the red sea and in the
continuous red sea there would be
traffic lights everywhere
on the arterial roads that's the
continuous red sea
the utility of the red sea concept is
is that it allows one to think in terms
of green waves
since red light the red light state is
actually determined by the green waves
and so now i need to tell you what the
green waves are
and what their properties are so
imagine green waves traveling on the
continuous red sea
in in two in actually four orthogonal
directions north south east and west
uh those are just they're not
necessarily the geometric north south
east and west
they actually correspond just to four
orthogonal directions
that we arbitrarily call north south
east and west
then vehicles like surfers wait for a
green wave to come by
and then they ride them to shore however
in that case
the green waves never stop moving which
means that vehicle to ride the green
wave
never stop for traffic light we also
have to demand
that the waves never intersect one
another
that's an essential requirement and what
it does is it avoids vehicle collisions
because we want our system to be
a maximum potential flow system
we demand that green waves have the
property
that when one leave one wave leaves the
intersection
another green wave in the orthogonal
direction enters the intersection
and as you can imagine this property
ensures maximum potential flow at each
intersection
we we require greenways move with the
same speed
in the two orthogonal directions this
requirement is reasonable
since the hypothetical road network is
isotropic however
this requirement is imposed for
analytical convenience
and when we apply our theory to real
cities
which i'm not going to do in this talk
then the the the fact that
we will relax the requirement the
vehicles
travel at the same speed in the two
directions
now what is the motorist objective
the motorist's goal is to catch a green
wave
and ride it as long as the motorist
travels on a particular road
the motorist who changes to an
orthogonal road
tries to catch a green wave on that road
before being stopped by a traffic light
and the motorist may or may not be
successful when he changes roads
the continuous red sea in a continuous
red sea a motorist is stopped
by a red light the moment a motorist is
outside the green wave
in the in the real situation where you
have a digital red sea
the motorist is stopped if he's outside
a green wave
when the motor is first encounters a
traffic light
okay so now we we we introduced the idea
of green waves in the fundamental
problem
so if you can find green waves that
satisfy green wave properties
you will have solved the fundamental
problem
and you can wonder do any green waves
with the specified properties
exist the short answer is yes
the longer answer is the length of the
green waves
have discrete values to satisfy non-stop
and maximum flow
rate requirements in the subsequent
paper
uh dr mark and i will write
a cl planning a paper called
introduction to green wave theory
now there's also a need
for green arrows
and you may say why do you need green
arrows
well traffic lights on existing roads
have a short period when the traffic
light is red
in two orthogonal directions the traffic
lights of course also have an amber
interval
these features are not captured in the
green wave concept
but are captured in the green arrow
concept
so what is the green arrow concept
the green arrows are basically a
generalization of the green wave concept
as a generalization they move at the
same speed as green waves
and they're useful they're a useful
concept for traffic light control
and what we what we envision is that the
movement of green arrows
on the red sea controls traffic light
behavior
so when the tip of a green arrow enters
an intersection
it turns the light green although it's
not shown in our diagrams
we can imagine that the tail of the
green arrows
have amber tail feathers and the shaft
after the tail feathers is red so when
the tail feathers pass to an
intersection
they turn the traffic light amber and
when the shaft
aft of the tail feathers enters an
intersection
it turns the traffic light red now
there's another concept that we need
for this all this to work and that's a
road to travel a feedback device
and the purpose of the road to travel a
feedback device
is that it informs motorists how fast
the green wave is moving
and where the traveler is relative to
the green
arrow so this for example over here this
a black a spot here represents the
particular vehicle that you're
in and here is the
green wave you're riding in
this says that it's going at 35 miles
per hour
and as long as you stay in this green
rectangle
you're guaranteed to make all the lights
with this background you're you're ready
i i'm now going to convince you that
of the the it is possible
to coordinate traffic lights with
maximum potential flow
so that you can make every traffic light
if you go with the recommended speed
and here's an illustration of how that
works
on a a city remember these blocks are
half a mile
in in size so this is a city that's
roughly three miles by three miles
since there are six blocks along the
horizontal and six along
of the vertical and you'll notice that
uh at any given intersection for example
if we look here the moment the green
arrow leaves an intersection
another green arrow enters the
intersection and that means
if these green arrows are are completely
full
of of vehicles then
this network will have the maximum
possible flow
you can have uh now
you'll also notice that what i've done
is this is
here i've coordinated traffic lights on
an
alternate a system of alternate one-way
streets
and you may wonder well is it possible
to do this on two-way streets
and my next presentation will show you
that it's possible to do it on two-way
streets
so here are two-way streets
and and you can see
the vehicles are going in both
directions on the street
and you'll also notice that each
intersection is utilized fully
since whenever a green arrow leaves any
particular intersection another green
arrow enters it
so that if these green arrows
were full of vehicles through a lot of
vehicles traveling with each green arrow
this would have the maximum potential
flow
possible however
in the two presentations that i've given
you up to now
i assumed that there was an equal demand
for flow in the north south east and
west direction
so the these diagrams show equal flow
in all four orthogonal directions
uh and the next demonstration
will show you that you can
still achieve maximum uninterrupted flow
with a system
of an isotropic vehicles
so i'll start the demonstration going
and i'll slow it down so that you can
see how it goes i'll also show that
it works for a city of arbitrary size
cn over here and over here
determines uh how large a city is so i
can make the city larger
and start the and start the
the presentation again
and you may be interested the alpha
actually controls the width of the
streets
so if i increase see i'm making the
streets wider now
as i click on that so i i
my my animation allows for variable with
streets and also an arbitrary number of
blocks
and and you see that this is
an isotropic flow because
the arrows in the east and western
direction
are much longer than the ones in the
north-south direction
and essentially what that means is that
the lights are green
in the east-west direction for a longer
period of time than they are in the
north-south direction
now what i've done here is i've shown
that you can have
maximum anisotropic flow
on a system of alternate one-way streets
and you may be wondering is it possible
for me to achieve this
on a system of two-way roads and
the next the next demonstration will
show
that it's possible to do this on a
system of two-way roads
so here you can see there are two
two-way roads with the north-south
arrows being
short and the east-west arrows being
long
and now i'll start the animation
and i'll slow it down so that it goes
more more smoothly
i'll speed it up a little bit so you see
that the animation can go at any speed
and this property you can basically
adjust the speed with which the green
narrows move
you can adjust that to the density of
vehicles on the road
and so what i've shown you up to this
point
is that i can have i can satisfy
the fun the fundamental a question i can
answer
i showed that the answer has a positive
solution
for alternate one-way roads
two-way roads for isotropic flow
and for an isotropic flow but
the last two anisotropic flows
had equal flow in the
east-west direction an equal flow in the
north-south direction
and you may wonder if you can make it
even more anisotropic than that
can you make it so that there's a
greater flow
toward toward the city
in the morning and away from the city in
the evening
and still maintain uninterrupted
maximum flow and the next demonstration
will show that that too
is possible
so i've just executed this and
here you see we have a road
we we have basically we have two way
roads
here's road heading north and south
and here and here's a road heading east
and west
but here's a road that's only heading
west
and here's the road that's only heading
west and now i'll
i'll get that animation going
and i'm going to slow it down a little
bit
and and once again you see it's a
maximum flow
network in the sense that
as soon as one green arrow leaves an
intersection
another green arrow enters the
intersection
you can also see though that it's not
isotropic
because of this road and this road
there's considerably more traffic
heading in the western direction
than there is in the eastern direction
and actually
i i stopped this but you have seen
that this arrow makes all
all of the it never intersects any of
the
east or west going arrows so i can
replace this arrow
by i i can replace this arrow
with one that moves with this one and
that way i would have
enhanced traffic i would have enhanced
traffic
with two streets heading west and one
track
one one street heading exclusively north
and so you see i have very very good
control
over the nature of the anisotropic flow
and i can adjust the anisotropic flow
i can adjust it to the demand
that the drivers want so if more drivers
want to head
north but more drivers want to head east
i can do that
now i'll go on to the next slide
i gave you a brief overview
of the road to travel the feedback
device now i'll go into it a little more
detail
why do you need the device well
the green arrow speed depends on the
time of the day
in existing cities green arrows
move at a variable speed because of
uneven block spacing
so if you keep the traffic timing the
same
you can compensate for the fact that
some blocks are longer
by having the the green arrow speed up
on those blocks
another reason you uh the green arrow
speed changes
is because in the morning and in the
evening during rush hour
the density of cars on the road is
rather high
and for that reason the green arrows
have to slow down
because without much space between your
vehicle and the one in front of you you
just can't travel
as fast and
and i have already shown you that the
green arrows can
speed up or slow down regardless
you know as needed and and so you need a
way to tell
the motorist how quickly the green
arrows are going
and and so the people who can use the
road to travel the feedback device
are motorist bicyclists and pedestrians
and with few exceptions the device
allows travelers to make every light
now i'll show you what the road to
traveler the
device appears like
so i've already explained this is the
vehicle
this red this red line over here
indicates that motorists are not
permitted to make a left turn
during rush hour these dotted red lines
over here
not drawn quite to scale uh indicate to
the motorists
that when these uh
dashed red lines are in an intersection
motor pedestrians will have a chance
to cross the street going from here to
here
or from the from there to there
uh and so a motorist who wants to make a
right turn
and wants to avoid pedestrian walk
signal
would then try and position himself so
that is between the two
sets of dashed red lines
this indicates that the green arrow is
moving at 35 miles per hour
so that if a motorist was outside of the
green wave
he could do either one of two things he
could speed up to catch the green wave
ahead of him
to make all the traffic lights or if he
was over here
he might slow down so that he's at the
beginning of the next green wave
and and when the device is fully zoomed
it shows what the cross street will be
and the device input requirements
uh essentially well i'll i'll do it in
detail
i'm running out of time but when the
device is turned on
it asks the user if the
input if if the if the input data has
changed since the device was last
used so basically when you turn the
device on it wants to know if you're a
motorist bicyclist or pedestrian
and if it hasn't changed you just press
enter
if you're a motorist it'll ask you what
your destination is
and if you want to give your destination
you give it by saying
by verbal command and if you don't want
to give your destination you just press
enter the purpose of giving your
destination
is that if there is a an accident or
some traffic jam on the particular road
you're on
then the device can alert you that you
should switch roads
and which road you should switch to to
avoid the traffic jam
it also asks you your maximum
comfortable speed the default being the
speed limit
and you can press enter if you want to
use the default it will
also ask you to state your lower maximum
driving speed
which uh the default the default value
was something like 15 or 20 miles per
hour
and uh this this tells the mo
the device how fast and how slow you're
willing to drive to avoid being stopped
by a traffic light and
uh and
and the same thing is true for
bicyclists and pedestrians
and with that input the device can now
put
i'll give the device output
the device output uh gives you the speed
of the green
the green the green wave and it tells
you it tells the position
of the traveler in the it tells you
where
you are relative to the green wave so
that you'll know whether to go
to speed up to slow down or what you
should do to make the
green light and and uh
uh yeah so now i'll go on to the next
this can be used in existing cities but
in existing cities because existing
cities don't have the road system that i
have presented here you won't make every
traffic light
and you and you can't you can no longer
go with a constant average speed
your average speed will have to vary
between traffic lights
and essentially what will happen when
you apply it to an existing street
existing city is that you'll have
regions of the city where motorists can
make every traffic light
but as you travel from region to region
you will be stopped by a traffic light
this uh this analysis i've done up to
here
assumed ideal drivers and ideal drivers
are one who try to get in and travel
with the green wave
analysis shows that
non-ideal drivers will not be a
long-term problem
finally i come to my conclusions and i
wanted to say
mathematica greatly facilitated
discovering results
and communicating results to others the
animations and videos
using this presentation were made with
mathematica
and all the diagrams in this
presentation were made with mathematica
and now i will entertain
questions uh
okay john john asked the question
how does the system adjust for uh
traffic lights on major roads which are
triggered only by demand
e.g a car pulling out of a subdivision
a housing road
i'll try and answer that
the when when
when a car uh tries to go on a major
road
if the major road uh
if the major road is not heavily
trafficked then
the then the person coming out of the
intersection
uh will trigger a green light in
in the cross direction what i have done
is i've shown the analysis during peak
hours
and during peak hours that is during
rush hour
because i was oriented toward having
this
work uh during rush hour so you wouldn't
so people during rush hour could get
home quickly
so during rush hour they would get a
green light
when it was their turn for a green light
that is when a green wave went by
they they would have a green light so
that they could go and their
arriving at an intersection would not
trigger light
off hours the green wave on the red c
method is not needed because the green
wave on the red sea
is meant to give uninterrupted maximum
flow
and uh at late at night
when there's not much demand on the main
arterial
the uh a car coming out of
a subdivision would work would trigger
a green light for it just as it normally
does
let me see if there any other questions
i oh i need to refresh this
okay i don't see any other questions
or maybe okay i guess that ends my talk
i'd like to
thank you for attending and i hope you
enjoy the rest of your afternoon